Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的内容之前，我想先告诉大家一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我和我的商业导师Lisa Johnson共同推出的“循环收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, today's episode is all about autoethnography
这些原则都同样适用。你还有机会赢取由Lisa亲自提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南。节目。与Marianne Trent博士一起。嗨，今天的节目主题是“自动民族志”（autoethnography）。
And you might notice some slight weirdness when I say the word autoethnography Because I got to the end of filming all of it and I got to the end of that day I got to being in bed and I got to being asleep and then suddenly my brain woke me up in the middle of the night to make me wonder whether I had accidentally said ethnography all the way through instead of auto-ethnography and of course when I listened back to do the editing I had so I've tried to fix it where I can but you know perfectionism there's no place for it in modern mental health services and so I have just done the best I can. I hope this doesn't take away any enjoyment but please know that I am referring to autoethnography.
你可能会注意到，当我说“自动民族志”这个词时，听起来有点奇怪。因为我在录制完所有内容后，到了那天深夜，我躺在床上准备睡觉时，大脑突然把我叫醒，让我怀疑自己是不是全程把“自动民族志”说成了“民族志”。当然，当我回听进行剪辑时，发现确实如此。所以我尽可能地进行了修正，但你知道，完美主义在现代心理健康服务中是没有立足之地的，所以我已经尽力了。希望这不会影响你的收听体验，但请知悉我所指的确实是“自动民族志”。
Hope you find it really useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. Thank you for listening. It means a great deal to me. And I record this at the point where we are at about 2,500 downloads of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. And that just is incredible to me you know I hatched this idea in my kitchen one day as I cooked tea and the idea that people are really enjoying it and finding it beneficial and helpful is just you know so validating and so wonderful and energizing to me. So, you know, I set out to hope that this would be useful and it turns out that it is. It's been really nice hearing people's
希望你觉得它非常有用。嗨，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。感谢你的收听，这对我很重要。录制这一期时，我们的下载量已经达到了约2500次。这对我来说简直不可思议，你知道吗？我某天在厨房做饭时萌生了这个想法，而现在人们真的很喜欢它，并从中受益，这对我来说是非常有价值、非常美妙且充满活力的。所以，我当初希望它能有所帮助，事实证明它确实做到了。听到人们的
stories about what they are doing and how they are doing it whilst listening. So some people have been in contact to say that I am their running companion or their companion for out walking the dog. You know, they've got me in their ears as they are out and about. You know, some people really like to step it up when the jingles come along. That's their chance to sprint. And other people say that even though they're not psychologists, they like listening to this because it really helps them think about mental health. It helps them think about how therapy is put together. And also some people say they use me to listen to as they are going off to sleep. And I shan't take that too personally but people say that they like my voice which is just
故事，了解他们在收听时正在做什么以及如何做，感觉真的很棒。有些人联系我说，我是他们跑步时的伙伴，或者是遛狗时的陪伴。你知道，他们在我说话时正忙着自己的事。有些人说，当片头音乐响起时，他们会加快步伐，那是他们冲刺的机会。还有些人说，即使他们不是心理学家，也喜欢听这个节目，因为它能帮助他们思考心理健康问题，思考治疗是如何构建的。也有人说他们会在睡前听我的节目。我不会太往心里去，但人们说他们喜欢我的声音，这真的
really nice so thank you but in the in the most part I believe our our audience are mainly listening apparently on Spotify but there's lots of other ways you can listen as well. So Apple podcasts, Amazon Music, Google podcasts, you can watch on YouTube as well. This is, you know, largely helpful for an aspiring psychologist audience. And, you know, your feedback is so welcome. If you want to get involved with the podcast and you'd like to leave an audio testimonial, either for the podcast itself or for one of my books, then please do check out my website. There's details in the links section for how you can get involved, how you can download information about how to create your audio testimonial. It could just be your little thank you to me
非常好，所以谢谢你们。但总的来说，我相信我们的听众主要是在Spotify上收听，当然还有很多其他方式。比如Apple Podcasts、Amazon Music、Google Podcasts，你也可以在YouTube上观看。这对于有抱负的心理学家听众来说非常有帮助。而且，你的反馈非常受欢迎。如果你想参与播客，并愿意留下音频感言，无论是针对播客本身还是我的书，请务必查看我的网站。链接部分有关于如何参与以及如何下载音频感言制作指南的详细信息。这可以作为你对我的一个小小的感谢，
if you are enjoying the content. I would so, so welcome it. I'd be really grateful. So thank you for that. And if you are listening on Apple Podcasts, please take just two seconds to scroll down to where the trailer is right at the bottom of all of the episodes and just click rate.
如果你喜欢这些内容的话。我会非常、非常欢迎，也会非常感激。所以谢谢你们。如果你是在Apple Podcasts上收听，请花两秒钟向下滚动到所有剧集底部的预告片位置，点击评分。
Just click rate rate out of five stars how much you're enjoying the podcast. And if you have one minute more than that, could you maybe leave me a review for the podcast? That would be so appreciated. And why that is helpful is because podcasts with more reviews and more ratings get shown to more people. And it empowers people to give podcasts a chance if they can see that other people who might be people just like them are finding it useful. Why do we like what others have got to say? And this is going to be the topic for our podcast today. Why is it useful to hear how other people have done things and why? I know that this is certainly a way that I learn really well from working with clients, but also from reading books and it is a form of um literature
只需点击评分，给出你对播客的喜爱程度（五星制）。如果你还有一分钟时间，能不能为播客写一条评论？那将不胜感激。这样做之所以有帮助，是因为拥有更多评论和评分的播客会被推荐给更多人。如果他们看到其他可能和他们一样的人觉得它很有用，这会鼓励更多人给播客一个机会。为什么我们喜欢听别人的见解？这将是我们今天播客的主题。为什么听听别人是如何做事的很有用？我知道这确实是我从与客户合作、阅读书籍中学到东西的一种方式，这是一种被称为
called auto ethnography which is just beautiful um and it's something that i've always been interested in but i didn't realize that there was like a word for it a phrase for it and it's actually only after i published the Clinical Psychologist Collective that I realised that that is what we are doing in the book. So autoethnography is a way of learning or a way for someone to talk about themselves and their experiences by talking exactly about themselves, by talking about their own personal accounts and reflections. So I guess technically it could be thought of as a type of research, an ethnographical account or an ethnographical piece of research. So perhaps grounded theory strays into ethnographic territory as well.
“自动民族志”的文学形式，它非常美。我一直对它很感兴趣，但我以前不知道它有一个专门的词汇。其实是在我出版了《临床心理学家合集》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）之后，我才意识到我们在书中做的正是这件事。所以，自动民族志是一种学习方式，或者说是某人通过谈论自己、谈论个人的经历和反思来讲述自己的方式。所以我想从技术上讲，它可以被视为一种研究，一种民族志叙述或民族志研究作品。也许扎根理论也涉足了民族志领域。
But I have always learned really well from being able to hold in mind case stories and case histories. And so that, for me, is what is going on in the Clinical Psychologist Collective and in the Grief Collective. And may this be a little exclusive scoop that you are the first people to hear about this. There is another book coming because, you know, the Clinical Psychologist Collective is great if you are already on the path and looking to apply to become a clinical psychologist. But I know that some people are not yet there. You know, you may be listening to this podcast because you are, you know, perhaps studying psychology either at university or maybe even college. I know we've got some college and sixth form students listening too. And why this can be really useful is because it can help you
但我一直通过在脑海中保留案例故事和病史来学习。对我来说，这就是《临床心理学家合集》和《悲伤合集》（Grief Collective）中正在发生的事情。请允许我透露一个小独家，你们是第一批听到这个消息的人。还有另一本书即将出版，因为《临床心理学家合集》对于那些已经在路上并寻求申请成为临床心理学家的人来说很棒。但我知道有些人还没到那一步。你可能正在听这个播客，因为你可能正在大学甚至学院学习心理学。我知道我们也有一些学院和预科学生在听。这之所以非常有用，是因为它可以帮助你
think about what your next step job will be or what it could be, what route to becoming whatever type of qualified psychologist is on your wish list might be useful for you. And so the book that is coming, there's a working title for it the aspiring psychologist collective and it is going to include the ethnographic accounts of people who are not yet on clinical training so there might be some stories in there of people who are having interviews for for either educational psychology or clinical psychology, you know, maybe forensic psychology this year. So it's going to be a really current finger on the pulse kind of book, you know, I'm hoping to have it published for October so that we can see out
思考你的下一份工作会是什么，或者可能是什么，以及成为你愿望清单上任何类型的合格心理学家可能对你有用的路径。所以即将出版的那本书，暂定名为《有抱负的心理学家合集》（The Aspiring Psychologist Collective），它将包含那些尚未进入临床培训的人的民族志叙述。所以里面可能会有一些人正在参加教育心理学、临床心理学，或者法医心理学面试的故事。所以这将是一本非常前沿、紧跟脉搏的书。我希望能在十月份出版，这样我们就能见证
this cycle of certainly clinical applications. And I am asking for aspiring psychologists who are already on their path to their chosen psychology career to get involved. So at this point in time, I'm asking for you to, you know, get in contact and show interest in writing and to then submit a few hundred words with a little bit of information about you and what you'd propose to write in your story and then I will be collating those to make sure that we've got a real medley of stories within the book and then if I ask you to write it I would want that back I guess by September so I haven't quite sorted out the dates yet this is hot off the press so I'm going to be working feverishly to get all this sorted so that when this podcast episodes goes live the details are all there in the show notes for how you can find out
这一轮临床申请周期。我正在邀请那些已经在通往心理学职业道路上的有抱负的心理学家参与进来。所以现在，我邀请你联系我，表达你的写作兴趣，然后提交几百字的内容，包括一点关于你的信息以及你打算在故事中写些什么。然后我会整理这些内容，确保书中有一个真正多样化的故事组合。如果我邀请你撰写，我希望能在九月前收到稿件。我还没完全确定日期，这还是新鲜出炉的消息，所以我将忙于处理所有这些细节，以便当这期播客上线时，节目说明中会有关于你如何找到更多信息的详细内容。
more information if indeed you would like to for anyone who has a story published in the aspiring psychologist collective i will be rewarding you with a paperback copy once it is published. That's obviously going to be a lot easier for me to sort out if you are in the UK. If you're not in the UK, it's perhaps not a deal breaker. But yeah, I would imagine that because the majority of our audience are UK based, that it will be UK based people that are writing stories. But if you are not UK based and you are still interested in thinking about whether you could add some narratives, add your own ethnographical accounts, then please do request more information. Because, of course, it's relevant and it's, you know, it's going to be engaging and relatable for people who are then going to buy the book, hopefully, in future. And also, it's really useful for you to do as a reflective account in your own right.
如果你确实想参与的话。对于任何在《有抱负的心理学家合集》中发表故事的人，一旦出版，我将奖励你一本平装本。如果你们在英国，这对我来说显然更容易处理。如果不在英国，这可能也不是决定性因素。但我想，因为我们的大多数听众都在英国，所以写故事的人应该也是英国人。但如果你不在英国，但仍然有兴趣考虑是否可以增加一些叙述，添加你自己的民族志记录，那么请务必索取更多信息。因为这当然是相关的，而且对于未来购买这本书的人来说，它将是引人入胜且容易产生共鸣的。此外，作为你自己的反思记录，这也是非常有用的。
So I know when people put together their accounts for the Grief Collective and the Clinical Psychologist Collective, they found it a really you know fulfilling experience in itself so i hope that you will find that really useful and that you will want to get on board and to kind of get that out there as a dissemination as well as a bit of a publication for you for your own cv which would be really useful for you for your own CV, which would be really useful for you. But of course, useful for so many people who want to do what you do one day. So it might be that you're a research assistant. It might be that you're a psychology assistant and assistant psychologist. It might be that you're a psychological well-being practitioner. It might be that you're, you know, a high intensity or low intensity CBT therapist. It might be that you're doing, you know, care assistant work or mental health support worker or support role work. So I want to know, you know, and if you've done a few different roles, then I'd like to know about those as well.
我知道当人们为《悲伤合集》和《临床心理学家合集》整理他们的叙述时，他们发现这本身就是一种非常充实的经历。所以我希望你会觉得它非常有用，并希望你加入进来，将其作为一种传播方式，同时也作为你个人简历的一项出版物，这对你自己的简历非常有用。当然，对于许多未来想做你所做之事的人来说，它也非常有用。所以你可能是一名研究助理，可能是一名心理学助理，可能是一名心理健康从业者。可能你是一名高强度或低强度的CBT治疗师。可能你正在做护理助理工作、心理健康支持工作或支持性角色工作。所以我想知道，如果你做过几种不同的角色，我也想了解这些。
So, yeah, I hope that this sounds really exciting and that you are keen to request more information. Let's just take a quick pause here to hear a little bit more about the Clinical Psychologist Collective. And I will be back shortly so that we can talk more about why and how autoethnography is useful to us, not only in clinical practice, but also when we're striving for our own goals too. And let this be your guide. Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective.
所以，是的，我希望这听起来非常令人兴奋，并且你渴望索取更多信息。让我们在这里暂停一下，听听关于《临床心理学家合集》的更多内容。我很快就会回来，这样我们就可以谈谈为什么以及如何将自动民族志应用于我们，不仅是在临床实践中，而且在我们为自己的目标奋斗时也是如此。让这成为你的指南。充满了将帮助你获得资格的经验教训。所以来看看吧。就在这本书里。这就是《临床心理学家合集》。
It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective The Clinical Psychologist Collective is a fantastic read for aspiring clinical psychologists. This book provides insights from real trainees and qualified psychologists. They offer their advice, hope, and encouragement to aspiring clinical psychologists. This book helps to put in perspective the variety of journeys people take to become qualified.
这就是《临床心理学家合集》。《临床心理学家合集》对于有抱负的临床心理学家来说是一本极好的读物。这本书提供了来自真实学员和合格心理学家的见解。他们为有抱负的临床心理学家提供了建议、希望和鼓励。这本书有助于从宏观角度看待人们成为合格心理学家所经历的各种旅程。
I would recommend this book to anyone interested in the Declclincy. experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. Welcome back. Thank you for listening. So before the break, we were thinking about what autoethnography is. And now this side of the break, we're going to be thinking about how and why this is useful. And for me, it's about the personal resonance. It's about the human story. It's about the connection. It's also about the, well, if they can do it, then so can I. I find it really helps bolster my faith in myself. It makes things seem so much
我会向任何对该领域感兴趣的人推荐这本书。经验教训将帮助你获得资格。所以来看看吧。就在这本书里。这就是《临床心理学家合集》。这就是《临床心理学家合集》。欢迎回来。感谢收听。休息前，我们思考了什么是自动民族志。现在休息回来，我们将思考它如何以及为什么有用。对我来说，它关乎个人共鸣。它关乎人类的故事。它关乎连接。它也关乎“如果他们能做到，那么我也能做到”。我发现它确实有助于增强我对自己的信心。它让事情看起来
more attainable, so much more relatable, because I can then hold in mind those case studies, you know, those examples. So when we open up the Clinical Psychologist Collective, the first story you'll read is by Dan. And Dan opens up the beginning of his story by explaining that he got a 2.2 at university. And then the story recounts how he has got onto the right track to then be a trainee clinical psychologist. So, you know, that is really heartening for people to think that actually it is possible. People are holding Dan in mind, thinking, well, if Dan can do it, then I can do it. It makes it, you know, more tangible, more achievable, more relatable. And I know when I was preparing for interviews, either as a qualified or as an aspiring psychologist, I would, you know, sit down and try
更容易实现，更容易产生共鸣，因为我可以记住那些案例研究，那些例子。所以当我们打开《临床心理学家合集》时，你读到的第一个故事是Dan写的。Dan在故事开头解释说他在大学里只拿到了2.2的成绩。然后故事讲述了他如何走上正轨，最终成为一名临床心理学实习生。所以，这对人们来说是非常令人振奋的，让他们认为这确实是可能的。人们会记住Dan，心想，如果Dan能做到，那么我也能做到。它让事情变得更具体、更可实现、更易产生共鸣。我知道当我准备面试时，无论是作为合格的还是有抱负的心理学家，我都会坐下来尝试
and put down sort of case studies of people that I'd worked with. So perhaps from, you know, a psychological perspective of depression, perhaps people that I'd worked with, with interventions, so, you know, for OCD, or, you know, panic. And I'd write up case studies about the client and how it worked well for them and what we did and what we were able to achieve. And for me, having those little sort of potted histories, it was then easy for me to be able to draw on that theory and to bring it to mind. And that for me, again, is what the Grief Collective and what the Clinical Psychologist Collective offers to you. It offers you the chance to have extra stories in your mind to reflect on, to draw upon,
写下我曾合作过的人的案例研究。也许是从抑郁症的心理学角度，也许是我曾用干预措施合作过的人，比如针对强迫症或恐慌症。我会写下关于客户的案例研究，以及它如何对他们有效，我们做了什么，我们能够实现什么。对我来说，拥有这些小小的“盆栽历史”，我就能很容易地利用这些理论并将其带入脑海。对我来说，这再次是《悲伤合集》和《临床心理学家合集》为你提供的。它为你提供了在脑海中反思、借鉴的额外故事，
to consolidate your own learning and to show you that everything and anything is possible. And this is the case for me as well. So coming up in a few weeks time, we've got another guest interview with a wonderful researcher and academic book producer. And I'm not going to tell you who she is, but it is going to be an incredibly useful resource. And for me, part of my journey into bookishness and beyond has been holding this lady in mind. You know, if she can do it, then I can do it. And I want you to be able to take from people in the Clinical Psychologist Collective. I want you to be able to take from the content I create for the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I would love to be part of your inner monologue. It would be an absolute privilege if that was starting to happen for you. I fully expect that the jingles are already part of your
以巩固你自己的学习，并向你展示一切皆有可能。对我来说也是如此。所以几周后，我们将有另一位嘉宾访谈，是一位出色的研究员和学术书籍制作人。我不会告诉你她是谁，但这将是一个非常有用的资源。对我来说，我走向书籍创作及以后的部分旅程就是一直记着这位女士。你知道，如果她能做到，那么我也能做到。我希望你能从《临床心理学家合集》中的人们身上汲取力量。我希望你能从我为《有抱负的心理学家播客》创作的内容中汲取力量。我很乐意成为你内心独白的一部分。如果那开始为你发生，那将是我的绝对荣幸。我完全相信片头音乐已经成为你
inner daily monologue. Are you singing them in the shower? Are you humming them to yourselves as you chop peppers? You you know I do hope so because yeah people have been saying they're really liking the jingles which is just lovely because as you know I'm a big big fan but yeah I would like to be on your team one of the good guys in your head that helps you know you can do this. It might be that some people in the past have told you that you can't or that you shouldn't or that you're bad. You know, no good will come from this. You should go and do something different.
日常内心独白的一部分了。你在淋浴时唱它们吗？你在切辣椒时哼唱它们吗？你知道，我确实希望如此，因为人们一直说他们真的很喜欢这些片头音乐，这太可爱了，因为如你所知，我是它们的超级粉丝。但是的，我想成为你的团队成员，成为你脑海中那些好人之一，帮助你知道你可以做到。过去可能有些人告诉你你做不到，或者你不应该做，或者你很糟糕。你知道，这不会有什么好结果。你应该去做点别的。
And it might be useful at this point for me to tell you about some feedback that I received about myself once upon a time. It was actually my grandfather. And he said, once upon a time, Marianne, listening to your voice is one of the most painful experiences of my life. And I think I was a bit sort of flabbergasted, really. I didn't quite know what to say and how to respond. So I'm not really sure that I did much at all in response to that. I was, of course, aware that he had been a paramedic in the Second World War. And so he had seen all sorts of awful things, you know, awful things, trauma. And yet, you know, what a thing to say to someone.
此时我告诉你一些我曾经收到的关于我自己的反馈可能很有用。其实是我祖父说的。他曾经说：“Marianne，听你的声音是我一生中最痛苦的经历之一。”我想我当时有点目瞪口呆，真的。我不知道该说什么，该如何回应。所以我不太确定我是否对此做了什么回应。我当然知道他曾是二战期间的医护兵。所以他见过各种可怕的事情，创伤。然而，对某人说出那样的话。
And this was at the point when I was striving to be a psychologist as well. So it really made me think, well, if my voice is that awful, how am I going to make a living out of this? How am I going to have people want to listen to what I've got to say? And this is why, you know, the feedback from my clients along the journey and the feedback from some of you guys as well. Actually, you like listening to my voice and that you find it calming and soothing and inspiring. It means a big deal. And actually, sometimes I think we can just treat feedback as erroneous, you know, not that helpful, kind of so left field that we just don't even need to take it on board. You know, people are entitled to their opinion. He passed away in 2012. So I'm never going to know what he, what exactly he meant by that. But nor do I need to let it trouble me any longer. You know, I heard it. I didn't like it. I can choose to move on from it.
那正是我努力成为心理学家的时候。所以这真的让我思考，如果我的声音那么糟糕，我怎么能靠这个谋生呢？我怎么能让人们想听我想说的话呢？这就是为什么沿途客户的反馈以及你们当中一些人的反馈。实际上，你们喜欢听我的声音，觉得它平静、舒缓且鼓舞人心。这意义重大。而且有时我认为我们可以直接把反馈视为错误的，你知道，没什么帮助，甚至离谱到我们根本不需要采纳。人们有权发表意见。他在2012年去世了。所以我永远不会知道他那句话到底是什么意思。但我也不需要再让它困扰我了。我知道了，我不喜欢它，我可以选择继续前进。
It's not a trauma. I can talk about it in a way that is connected, but not distressing, you know, not moving me to distress. And it's been, you know, I never would have imagined that it would be topic for a podcast. But know it is and in terms of my autography you know it's part of the story but it's not the whole story and it doesn't need to shape or define me so in the clinical psychologist collective there is a real flavor a real diversity of story and of route to becoming either a qualified clinical psychologist a trainee psychologist we've also got stories in there from educational psychologist forensic psychologist health and research psychologist and counseling psychologists psychologists as well because you know as we know the path is not always smooth to clinical
这不是创伤。我可以以一种连接但并不痛苦的方式谈论它，你知道，不会让我感到痛苦。我从未想过这会成为播客的主题。但现在它是了。就我的自动民族志而言，它是故事的一部分，但不是全部，它不需要塑造或定义我。所以在《临床心理学家合集》中，有一种真正的风味，一种故事和路径的多样性，无论是成为合格的临床心理学家、实习心理学家。我们还有来自教育心理学家、法医心理学家、健康和研究心理学家以及咨询心理学家的故事，因为正如我们所知，通往临床的道路并不总是平坦的。
but also clinical is not the only way you know there are absolutely other ways to go on and become a qualified psychologist and to offer your brilliance to the world in a way that might not involve ever going anywhere near being a clinical psychologist. So there is so much to learn from others. And I just adore this way of learning about people and, you know, becoming part of their world. So, you know, if you've been listening to the podcast for a little while now then hopefully you've enjoyed my little stories I know someone said that their favorite bit recently was when I was talking about being a millionaire feeling like a millionaire as you walked on the carpet with your shoes on but hopefully you like my little anecdotes and you know they might just serve you well at a time where you are needing some examples
但临床也不是唯一的途径，你知道，绝对还有其他方式可以继续成为一名合格的心理学家，并以一种可能永远不需要接近临床心理学家的方式向世界贡献你的才华。所以从别人身上可以学到很多东西。我只是非常喜欢这种了解人的方式，并成为他们世界的一部分。所以，如果你已经听了一段时间的播客，那么希望你喜欢我的小故事。我知道有人说他们最近最喜欢的部分是我谈论穿着鞋子走在地毯上感觉像个百万富翁的时候。但希望你喜欢我的小轶事，它们可能在你需要一些例子的时候为你服务，
to draw upon a point of pressure they might just serve you well when your inner critic chimes in you know some of the stuff we've spoken about might rise up for you as a compassionate other to say, actually, that might not be that useful. So, yeah, what we are doing is important and what is on offer in the Clinical Psychologist Collective and the Grief Collective is really useful and could really help shape the way that you're thinking about your client work, the way that you're thinking about striving for your future goals as well, and to help you balance where you are yourself and how that might look for you. You know, you might find it helpful to, you know, scribble all over the book if that doesn't break all your book reading rules. There's a very few number of books in my life
在压力点时，当你的内心批评者响起时，它们可能为你服务。你知道，我们谈论的一些东西可能会作为一种富有同情心的他人出现，说：“实际上，那可能没那么有用。”所以，我们正在做的事情很重要，《临床心理学家合集》和《悲伤合集》中提供的内容确实很有用，真的可以帮助塑造你对客户工作的思考方式，以及你对未来目标的追求方式，并帮助你平衡你自己的位置以及它对你来说可能的样子。你知道，如果这不违反你所有的读书规则，你可能会发现乱涂乱画很有帮助。我生命中只有极少数书
that I've allowed myself to write in. But if I had not put this book together myself, I do believe I would be, you know, highlighting and annotating and adding, you know, those little sticky note things, two pages in the Quincyte Collective so that I could draw upon it and so I could put it into themes that resonated with me. So yeah, do your worst if that doesn't break all your rules about how to look after books. I hope you found this episode really useful, really thought provoking about what your own ethnography might look like. And like I said, if you'd like to get involved with your own story for the Aspiring Psychologist Collective, then do check out the details in the show notes
是我允许自己写字的。但如果不是我自己整理了这本书，我相信我会高亮、注释，并添加那些小贴纸，以便我可以借鉴它，并将其归纳为与我产生共鸣的主题。所以，如果这不违反你关于如何爱护书籍的所有规则，那就尽情发挥吧。我希望你觉得这一集非常有用，非常发人深省，关于你自己的民族志可能是什么样子。正如我所说，如果你想为《有抱负的心理学家合集》贡献你自己的故事，请务必查看节目说明中的详细信息，
for how you can request more information. But if you head to my website, which is goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk and then head to my books, there will be information there for you please do come and connect with me on socials as you might know by now i am dr marianne trent on linkedin dr marianne trent on instagram twitter i am good thinking ps1 and Facebook you can come and grab me on my personal account Marianne Trent or my business account which is good thinking psychological services when there are interview episodes all of them are available to watch on YouTube but even the audio versions are also available on YouTube too, which is Good Thinking
了解如何索取更多信息。但如果你前往我的网站 goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk，然后点击我的书籍，那里会有相关信息。请务必在社交媒体上与我联系，如你现在所知，我在LinkedIn上是Dr. Marianne Trent，在Instagram和Twitter上是Dr. Marianne Trent，我是Good Thinking PS1，在Facebook上你可以通过我的个人账户Marianne Trent或我的商业账户Good Thinking Psychological Services找到我。当有访谈节目时，所有节目都可以在YouTube上观看，音频版本也可以在YouTube上找到，即Good Thinking
Psychological Services. Come and subscribe, come and like, and come and comment on an episode. Give me your favourite emoji in the comments so that I know that you've been listening and that what we do matters to you. Help us spread the word and just, you know, be on my team like I'm on yours because it's so appreciated. Looking forward to catching up with you for our next episode very soon. and resources for interview season for psychology, then we have currently, as I record this, got the first compassionate Q&A available on YouTube for you to watch on replay. People found it really useful, soothing, calming, validating, inspiring,
Psychological Services。来订阅、点赞并评论一集吧。在评论中给我留下你最喜欢的表情符号，这样我就知道你在收听，而且我们所做的事情对你很重要。帮助我们传播这个消息，就像我支持你一样支持我，因为这非常令人感激。期待很快在下一集中与你相见。以及心理学面试季的资源，那么正如我录制时所说，我们目前在YouTube上有了第一个富有同情心的问答回放供你观看。人们觉得它非常有用、舒缓、平静、有价值、鼓舞人心，
all of that good stuff. So do check that out. And I will look forward to catching up with you through our next episode of The Aspiring Psychologist very soon. Take care. Being well supported during any interview season is so important. I have therefore planned some compassionate question and answer support sessions for you. You are absolutely welcome to come along to all of them, some of them, none of them. No need to book and here are the dates for you. Monday the 28th of February from 7.30pm, Monday the 21st of March 7.30pm, Monday the 4th of April 7.30pm and Monday the 9th of May 7.30pm. And they will all
所有这些好东西。所以一定要去看看。我期待很快通过《有抱负的心理学家》的下一集与你相见。保重。在任何面试季得到良好的支持都非常重要。因此，我为你计划了一些富有同情心的问答支持会议。非常欢迎你参加所有、部分或不参加。无需预约，以下是日期：2月28日星期一晚上7:30，3月21日星期一晚上7:30，4月4日星期一晚上7:30，以及5月9日星期一晚上7:30。它们都将
be live streaming via my socials, which includes Twitter, YouTube, LinkedIn and Facebook. So you can absolutely pick your favourite platform and they'll all be available on replay as well hope you find it so useful and i will look forward to catching up with some of you then take care if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast that's your side to be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast. With Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner.
通过我的社交媒体进行直播，包括Twitter、YouTube、LinkedIn和Facebook。所以你绝对可以选择你最喜欢的平台，它们也都会有回放。希望你觉得它很有用，我期待到时候与你们中的一些人交流。保重。如果你正在寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南。有了这个播客，这就是你通往合格之路的伙伴。《有抱负的心理学家播客》。与Marianne Trent博士一起。我叫Yana，是一名心理健康从业实习生。
I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。有多少种不同的途径可以达到目标让我感到惊讶，而且没有成为心理学家的完美方式。这让我充满了信心，不再觉得我在做错什么，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始，你就不会放下这本书。此剧集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。